[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اقتحمت وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه قريه العيساوي شرق مدينه تال
الابيض واعتقلت عددا من ابنائها وصادرت
املاكا عائده لاهلها كما شنت الوحدات حمله
اعتقال في تل ابيض وصادرت ممتلكات تعود
لمدنيين في المدينه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في
محورين ما حقيقه ارتكاب وحدات الحمايه
الكرديه مجازره وعمليات تطهير عرقي في تل
الابيض وهل يسعى الاكراد لانشاء دوله
كرديه في سوريا على غرار اقليم كردستان
[موسيقى]
العراق وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه تفس
سيطرتها على مدينه تان الابيض القريبه من
الحدود التركيه السوريه بعد انسحاب مسلحي
تنظيم الدوله منها تلى ذلك اتهامات لهذه
القوات بارتكاب مجازر وعمليات تطهير عرقي
بحق المدنيين العرب والتركمان من المدينه
والقرى القريبه منها وهي اتهامات ينفيها
الاكراد ما حقيقه هذه الاتهامات وما هي
ابعادها على الخارطه السياسيه والميدانيه
في سوريا تقرير زياد بركات يحمل بعض
الاجوبه
تحسم معركه ت الابيض سريعا ثلاثه ايام
كانت كافيه لوحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
لتلحق بتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه ما بدا ولو
شكليا على الاقل واحده من اسوا الهزائم لم
تكن وحدات حمايه الشعب وحدها تقدم عناصرها
تحت غطاء جوي من قوى التحالف الدولي قصفوا
ودمروا ومهدوا الطريق امامها في سيناريو
شبيه بعين العرب كوباني بعد سيطرتهم على ت
الابيض فع علت القوات الكرديه ما هو اسوا
اقتحمت قريه العيساوي المجاوره وشنت حمله
اعتقالات وصادرت بيوتا للاهالي من غير
الكرد وفعلت الامر نفسه داخله الابيض وثمت
ما يتردد عن تهجير منهجي لسكان البلده من
العرب والتركمان وعن عمليات قتل بدوافع
انتقاميه وذهب السوريون في المعارضه
ومسؤولون اتراك للقول بان ثمه مؤشرات على
قيام القوات الكرديه بتطهير عرقي هناك اج
العرب والتركمان على الهجره وصادروا
بيوتهم في مسعا لتعديل الوضع الديموغرافي
للبلده والشيء نفسه قامت به وحدات حمايه
الشعب في المناطق المجاوره للقم مشلي
العام الماضي حيث اتهمهم معارضون السوريون
بتهجير نحو 40 الف سوري انذاك وبحسب البعض
فان ما تسعى اليه هذه القوات هو مناطق
صافيه عرقيا تتيح لهم ممارسه دور سياسي
اكبر شبيه لما فعل اكراد العراق العام
الماضي فسيطرت على تبيض تصبح قوات حمايه
الشعب قادره على ربط الحسكه بعين العرب
كوباني كما تصبح لها اليد الطوله على شريط
يبلغ طوله نحو 400 كت على الحدود مع تركيا
ذلك يجعلها لاعبا مهما وشريكا مفترضا
للامريكيين وقوات التحالف لمنع امدادات
تنظيم الدوله ويعتقد بان هذه القوات ومن
يقف وراءها يسعون الى لعب دور القوات
البريه التي يحتاجها التحالف الدولي على
امل الحاق الهزيمه بالتنظيم في سوريا
والعراق وثمه من اصبح يتحدث في البنتاجون
ودوائر البيت الابيض عن تل اببيض كمثال
يحتذى ففيها استخدمت القوه الجويه المدمره
جنبا الى جنب مع القوات البريه المدربه
جيدا ويقصد بها قوات حمايه الشعب على ان
ذلك يظل محفوفا بالمخاطر فحتى لو نجحت هذه
القوات بالتحول الى مخلب للقط الامريكي
فذلك سيكون اقصى ما تستطيع الحصول عليه
فسيني الانقسام دونه رفض بقيه مكونات
الشعب السوري ناهيك عن الرفض التركي وما
تفعله هذه القوات بغير الاكراد لا يراكم
سوى الكراهيه والاحقاد وذلك يسلب الاكراد
سرديته الكبرى عن مظلوميتهم القوميه
ويحيلهم من قضيه الى حاله يتخبط فيها
القومي بنزعته الانتقاميه العمياء وذاك ما
يجعل الكردي يخسر في نهايه المطاف موضوع
حلقتنا اليوم نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من لندن
السيد بسام جعاره الكاتب والاعلامي السوري
المعارض
ومن اسطنبول السيد سمير صلحه رئيس قسم
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه كوجا ايلي
وكذلك معنا من محافظه الحسكه من مدينه
عموده ناصر الحاج منصور مسؤول العلاقات في
هيئه الدفاع بالاداره الذاتيه لمقاطعه
الجزيره مرحبا بكم جميعا والسؤال لضيفنا
من الح من
الحسكه سيد ناصر الحاج
منصور يعني هناك اتهامات من المرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان لوحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
بانها تقوم بحمله تطهير عرقيه منظمه تحت
اشراف او تحت قصف وحمايه من قوات التحالف
من اجل تنفيذ
مخطط يجعل من اكراد سوريا وحده مستقله
بذاتها كما حدث في العراق هل
تؤيد هذه الاتهامات او
تنفيها منذ سنه او اكثر ووحدات حمايه
الشعب تحارب تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه هذا
التنظيم الارهابي العالمي الذي عجزت عن
مقاومتها وعجزت عن تصدي له دول بعينها
وحدات حمايه الشعب بدات تتصدى لها حتى من
دون المساعده الامريكيه حتى من دون مساعده
التحالف الدولي وحتى التحالف الدولي لم
يكن قد تشكل بعد لذلك اعتمدنا على منذ
البدايه على اننا قادرون على حمايه
مناطقنا واننا سنتصدى لهذا التنظيم
بال بالتكاتف مع المكونات الاخرى الموجوده
للشعب في هذه المنطقه ليس اساس عنصري وليس
على اساس طائفي وانما بتكاتف جميع
المكونات الموجوده داخل هذه المحافظه
والمحافظات الاخرى وفي كل المناطق الكرديه
وبهذا تمكنا من التصدي الى ان كان التحالف
الدولي ايضا الذي ساعد في كوبان وبعدها
ظهر التح والتنسيق بشكل اخر في مناطق
الجزيره وغيرها لكنني اتحدى من هذا المنبر
انه منذ اسابيع ومنذ ان بدات الابيض تدخل
في جدول اعمال او جدول نقاشات او جدول
الاعلام العالمي بداوا بدعوه او بحمله
كبيره واسعه شاسعه بناء على التعليمات
الموجهه من مراكز معينه سواء اقليميه كانت
او دوليه للتشهير بهذه الحمله قبل ان
تتحدى المشهرين بهذه الحمله وما دمت لحظه
لحظه ما دمت تستخدم ناء الفاعلين في كلامك
فان الفصائل بين قوسين الفصائل الثوريه
المسلحه او شركائكم في هذه الحمله يتهمون
صراحه بارتكاب عمليات تطهير عرقيه وتهجير
لمدنيين من العرب السنه والتركمان من تل
ابيض ومن غيرها من ريف الحسكه الغربي بصفه
عامه هؤلاء شركائكم الذين استدللت بهم اخي
الكريم اخي
الكريم اخي الكريم هذه هي الابيض واقفه
ومنصوبه امام اعيننا جميعا منذ اسبوعين
والكثير من بعض وبعض وسائل الاعلام تروج
لهذه المقوله بناء على مقولات اخرى ظهرت
قبلها واننا من هذا المنبر نتحدى وجود
دليل واحد كنا نحن نحن وحدات حمايه الشعب
بالاضافه الى بعض فصائل الجيش الحر اضافه
الى شمس الشمال وبركان الفرات وكلها كانت
في تل ابيض قاومت وطهرت تمكنت من تطهير تل
ابيض كلها من الدواعش وكان الاحرى بكم
وبالمجتمع الدولي كله ان يشكر هذه القوات
على انقاذ العالم وت الابيض نفسها من هذه
لكن بالنسبه للاتهامات وما تقولها اتهامات
ما هي الا اتهامات تظه تظهر جزافا لا اساس
لها من الحقيقه بشيء والعالم اليوم كله
موجود فيه وكل الصحفيين الذين حضروا الى
الى المنطقه والى ت الابيض نفسها اكدوا
انه ليس هناك بس لحظه لا اكمل لك اكدوا
جميعا انه ليس هناك تهير عرقي ومن على هذا
اضحت اتضحت الصوره فكرتك اتضحت يعني انت
تقول او تنفي صراحه وجود اي عمليات تطهير
عرقي هذه هذه فهمناها السيد بسام جعاره
السيد ناصر الحاج منصور استدل بشركائهم في
هذه المناطق في الحمله التي شنوها على
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه هناك هؤلاء
الشركاء نفسهم اصدروا بيانا حذروا فيه من
اي مخطط لتقسيم سوريا وقالوا ان وحده
التراب السوري خط احمر وهددوا بالرد على
عمليات تطهير العرقيه او التي وصفوها
بانها عمليات تطهير عرقي هل تعتقد ان هذا
يمهد لمعركه جديده بين الثوار وبين
الاكراد في مناطق سوريا الشماليه
الشرقيه يعني اسمح لي وارجو انك تعطيني
بعض الوقت لوضح الصوره ما يجري في طل
الابيض لا يمكن ان يكشف الا اذا علمنا
ماذا فعل هذا الفصيل الكردي منذ اليوم
الاول للثوره انا بدي احاول اختصر واقول
بسرعه منذ اليوم الاول للثوره وقف صالح
مسلم وحزبه ضد الثوره وضد المعارضين
الاكراد تحديدا ارتكبوا مجزره كبرى في
عموده والجميع يعلم ذلك ثم قتلوا الشهيد
مشعل تمه بدي ما اطول كثير بدي اقول ما
يلي هون بكل اسف يتبعون المدرسه
الاسرائيليه الان وبكل دقه كل من يتحدث عن
اجرام اسرائيل يتهم بالعداء لساميه وكل من
يتحدث عن اجرام حزب صالح مسلم يتهم بانه
داعشي الامر الاخر قالت جولدا مير في عام
67 العربي الجيد هو العربي الميت وهؤلاء
يقولون اليوم العربي الجيد هو العربي
الميت او العربي المهجر فقط بدي اعطي
مثالين صغيرين في 24 شباط من عام 2014
تحديدا دخلوا الى تل براك والقرى المحيطه
بها قتلوا 60 عربي واحرقوا 80 منزل في تل
براك والقرى المحيطه بها في واحد اار
اقتحموا تل الحميس والقرى المجاوره لها
وقتلوا حرقوا اكثر من 30 قريه وقتلوا
العشرات من السكان جنوب غربي راس العين
طهروا المنطقه بكامله كل المنطقه
الواقعه شرقي غرب وشرق الحسكه يمارس فيها
التطهير العرقي بكل وضوح هؤلاء كانوا وما
زالوا يصطفون مع بشار الاسد واريد ان
اعطيك الدليل هذا الكلام قاله البرزاني
قاله الجعفري في موسكو لصالح مسلم عندما
قال له كنا وما زلنا نعطيكم المال والسلاح
قبل يومين صحيفه باس الكرديه التي تصدر في
اربيل فضحت تواطؤ صالح مسدم مع ايران مع
حكومه العبادي مع النظام بمعنى اخر هم
ينفذون مخطط كردي بالتعاون مع كل هؤلاء
اما ما جرى في طل الابيض انا بدي اسال
المدينه كرد عربيه بامتياز هناك 10% من
الاكراد اتوا من عين العرب ولكنهم يزورون
الان ويقولون ان البلده عربيه بدي اعطي
مثال اوضح ياسين الحج صالح المفكر السوري
الشيوعي الذي يهاجم كل يوم بمناسبه وبدون
مناسبه كل التنظيمات
الاسلاميه اتهمهم بالاجرام بعد ان ضربوا
اخيه الشيوعي ايضا بمعنى اخر هم يتبعون
سياسه الارض مح
الكردي تثبت هذه الاتهامات بحق وحدات
حمايه الشعب سيد سمير صلحه من
اسطنبول السيد بولند ايرنج المتحدث باسم
الحكومه التركيه قال ان انقره تخشى من ان
يحاول اكراد سوريا اقامه منطقه حكم ذاتي
في المناطق الثلاثه عبر توحيد المناطق
الثلاثه على الحدود التركيه السوريه
كوباني والجزيره وعفرين هل هناك ما يبرر
هذه
المخاوف
طبعا يعني التطورات الميدانيه على الارض
هي التي تبرر ذلك برايي يعني اظن المشهد
بالنسبه لانقره شبه واضح انه الكيان
الكردي في شمال سوريا بات مساله شبه
محسومه لا نقاش اطلاقا النقاش هو مرحله ما
بعد هذا الكيان هل الخطه هي انه الجمع بين
اربيل والديار بكر باتجاه التمهيد للدوله
الكرديه الكبرى ام
انه هناك الان فتره
انتقاليه على ضوء المشهد السياسي في سوريا
بشكل عام من هنا اقول لك انه الكيان الان
في شمال سوريا برايي يبحث عن نقطه اساسيه
هيالي لا يتعلق بالمستقبل انا سنبحث هذا
في النصف الثاني من هذه الحلقه لكن في هذا
الجزء نحن نحاول ان نستكشف حقيقه
الاتهامات لوحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
بتجاوز حقوق الانسان في هذه المنطقه
بارتكاب مجازر كما يقال او عمليات تطهير
عرقي او انتهاكات بحق السكان هل هناك ما
يبرر هذه المخاوف التي عبر عنها ممثل
الحكومه
التركيه اظن انه هذه المخاوف مبنيه على
تقارير امنيه استخباراتيه وارده من الداخل
السوري بالنسبه
للقياده السياسيه في
تركيا المواقف والتصريحات التي اطلقتها
قيادات في المعارضه السوريه في الايام
الاخيره اولا ثانيا حركه النزوح
وال التهجير الذي باتجاه الاراضي التركيه
والتقارير التي جاءت الى انقره بناء على
كل هذه المعلومات الوارده تؤكد فعلا انه
هناك محاوله لتفريغ المناطق من سكانها
الاصليين
ونقل سكان جدد من مناطق اخرى في شمال
سوريا والمقصود هنا نقل جماعات كرديه من
منطقه الى منطقه بالنسبه لانقره ايضا هذه
النقطه لا نقاش اطلاقا حولها
لذلك يعني هي متمسكه بهذا الطرح وبهذه
الفكره سيد ناصر الحاج منصور نفس المسلك
الذي يعني يسلكه اكراد العراق او الذي
سلكه اكراد العراق وانتهى باستقلالهم
تقريبا باقليم كردستان العراق يسلكه الان
بدرجه ما او سلكه اتراك اكراد تركيا ضد
الحكومه المركزيه في انقره وتسلك الان في
منطقه الشمال الشرقي السوري لعلك استمعت
الى الاتهامات التي ساقها السيد بسام
الجعاره ازيدك من هذا ان بعض مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي نشرت صورا محروقه صورا
لمدينه او قريه الشيخ فوقاني وهي محترقه
تماما واتهمت وحدات حمايه الشعب الكردي
بانها هي من ارتكبت
ذلك لاعد الى الموضوع الاول وسعر على
الموضوع الثاني فيما بعد ان التقارير كلها
التي وصلت مننت الابيض وكل التقارير
الصحفيه التي ظهرت في الاعلام العالمي بما
فيها تقارير قناتكم العزيزه هي اكد هي
ايضا اكدت انه لا وجود لتطهير العرقي في
تل الابيض ليس هذا فحزب رئيسه الائتلاف
جاءت الى ت الابيض و وصرحت انه لا هناك
ليس هناك لا تهجير ولا تطير عرقي في هذه
المنطقه عضو الائتلاف ايضا جاء بالامس الى
الابيض وصرح علنا انه لا يوجد هناك طبعا
هناك معارك هناك حرب هناك حروق هناك بيوت
احترقت لكنني اتحدى بسام جعاره وغير بسام
جعاره ممن يقولون بهذه هذه اللهجه اتحدى
ان يذهبوا الى الى ت الابيض ويجدوا بيتا
واحدا قد احترق في في ت الابيض ويجد
مواطنا واحدا قد تعرض للاعتقال او
التعذيب بيتا واحدا
تعرض مجموعه من الوقائع المحدده قال لك في
تل حميس حدث كذا وفي غيرها حدث كذا وانت
لم ترد على هذه الوقا الكريم اخي الكريم
انا ايضا انا انا ايضا اقول لك هذه
الوقائع المحدده المساحه التي تم تحريرها
من
تقارب 9000 ك مربع اي تقريبا بمساحه لبنان
ونحن نحارب عدوا شرسا مثل داعش اذا كانت
قد حصلت عمليات احتراق او ما شابه او نزوح
فعمليات النزوح هي تختلف عمل عن عمليات
الاباده العرقيه او التطير العرقي لذلك
انا من هذا المنبر ومن منبركم اقول لكل
المنظمات العالميه بما فيها منظمه دول
الاسلاميه ومنظمه الدول العربيه وجامعه
الدول العربيه وحتى الامم المتحده بالحضور
الى ث الابيض وغيرها من المناطق التي تحدث
عنها جميعا وقد جاءت بعض اللجان في السابق
ايضا واكدت ان كل ما يقال عن هذا المجال
ليس الا اتهامات سياسيه لاهداف سياسيه لا
علاقه لها
بالحقيقه القاش
اار تبقوا معي ستكمل النقاش بعد فاصل قصير
نناقش بعده حقيقه الاتهامات الموجهه لقوات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه بارتكاب مجازر وتطهير
عرقي ضد العرب والتركمان في تل ابيض نرجو
ان تبقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الاعزاء في هذه
الحلقه من ما وراء الخبر التي تناقش حقيقه
الاتهامات الموجهه لقوات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه بارتكاب مجازر وتطهير عرقي ضد
العربي والتركمان في مدينه الابيض السوريه
وسؤالنا للسيد بسام جعاره الكاتب
والاعلامي السوري من مدينه لندن عاصمه
بريطانيا سيد بسام جعاره سمعت الدعوه التي
تقدم بها السيد ناصر الحاج منصور لكل
المعنيين في العالم بدءا من الامم المتحده
انتهاء باصغر منظمه معنيه بحقوق العرب او
بحقوق الانسان بالقدوم الى المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها وحدات حمايه الشعب والتحقق
والتثبت من الاتهامات الموجهه اليهم هل
وفى بذلك هل كفى هل يكفيك هذا هذه
الدعوه يعني انا تحدثت في البدايه عن
مجزره كبرى ارتكبت في عمودها في الايام
الاولى للثوره ضد الاكراد تحديدا يعني اي
ضد من يقف في وجه صالح مسلم ومن وقف بوجه
النظام بدي اسال الان وين موجودين اليوم
بالقامشلي كتف لكتف مع النظام يقاتلون مع
النظام ولكنهم يسعون لانشاء دوله كرديه
نحن نتحدث عن مناطق كبيره حتى تعرف حجم
المشكله مساحه الحسكه لوحدها 24000 ك م
مربع يعني قد مساحه لبنان مرتين ونص
يرسمون الان خرائط تمتد من المالكيه الى
القامشلي الى عموده الى راس العين الى تل
اببيض الى البحر المتوسط يتحدثون عن مرفع
ينشرون خرائط مكتوب عليها غربي كردستان
الامر ليس سرا انا وثقت وتحدثت عن عشرات
المجازر واسميه المناطق وهناك فيديوهات
حتى المرصد السوري الذي نتهمه بالانحياز
للنظام اشار الى ما جرى في تل الحميس والى
ما جرى في تل براك ايضا منظمه العفو
الدوليه اشارت الى ذلك هناك عشرات
التقارير حتى اسرائيل تقول اليوم انها لم
تفعل شيئا في غزه رغم كل القتل والدمار
الذي تم في غزه تقول اسرائيل تتحدى امس
واليوم تقول هذا الكلام يعني هذا الكلام
لا يقدم لا يؤخر هناك اجنده واضحه والاخطر
من ذلك ان معظ
المقول ان وكالات الانباء وقنوات الاخبار
هل تسمعني ويقول ان وكالات الانباء وقنوات
الاخبار تغض الطرف او لا تقول لا تشير الى
وجود اي مذابح او اي انتهاكات في هذه
المناطق كيف تفسر هذا لا تستطيع لا تستطيع
هذه الوسائل ان تصل الى تلك المناطق هذا
امر مؤكد هم يمنعون الجميع الان يعني بدي
اسال اليوم على سبيل المثال هل من مصلحه
تركيا ان تمنع عوده اللاجئين الى الى تل
الابيض ماذا فعلوا بما يسمى بين قوسين
الجيش الحر الذي شارك معهم في احتلال طل
الابيض ضربوهم طردوهم رفعوا العالم الكردي
في مدينه عربيه هم يفعلون ويمارسون تطهير
العرقي على شوف الامر لا يحتاج لا الى
لجان كما قال الائتلاف ولا الى اي شيء
اخر
الامريكان سيد سمير صالحه الان الان قد
سمعت ان مساله اقامه دوله كرديه في هذه
المناطق او استقلالها بحكم ذاتي لم يعد
سرا ينشرون خرائط ويرفعون العلم الكردي
الى اي مدى يمكن ان تذهب الدوله التركيه
في الحيلوله دون
ذلك يعني اظن هذه المساله يعني سيكون هناك
حدما رده فعل لتركيا عليها لانه هناك
عوامل الان ما زالت غامضه من الذي يشجع
اكراد سوريا للتحرك بهذا الشكل هل هناك
تنسيق مع قوى غربيه مثلا مشاركه الطيران
طيران التحالف الدولي في الغارات الاخيره
في تل الايض اغلق الاتراك كثيرا وكان هناك
رسائل مباشره الى واشنطن حول مخاطر هذه
الطريقه في التعامل مع هذه الملفات نقطه
ثانيه دائما كانت ورقه داعش تلعب ضد تركيا
بالامس كان هناك يعني حاله اثبتت انه فعلا
داعش هي ورقه بيد قوى
تحاول تسهيل بناء الكيان الكردي في شمال
سوريا كيف يكون هناك قتال شرس في كوباني
وتستسلم تل ابيض يغادرها داعش بمثل هذه
البساطه وهه لا تنسى سي
سم السيد صلاح الدين دميرتاش زعيم حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي في تركيا يتهم
الحكومه التركيه صراحه بانها تدعم تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه و يعني لعلك تذكر
التفجيرين الذين وقعا في ديار بكر قبيل
الانتخابات الاخيره وكيف اتهم منفذيها
بانهم تلقوا تدريبا على تنظيم الدوله بدعم
الحكومه
التركيه اظن هذه الاتهامات هي جزء من
محاوله اضعاف الموقف التركي وعزل تركيا
اكثر فاكثر انا اقول لك اكثر من ذلك تركيا
كان عندها دائما كما تعرف مشروع المنطقه
الامنه او المنطقه العازله في شمال سوريا
اولا لسال اللاجئين الى تلك المناطق
وثانيا لقطع الطريق على قوات النظام ما
الذي جرى الان في تل الابيض وكيف يتقدم
مشروع الكان الكردي نرى انه المنطقه
الامنه جزء من استراتيجيه غربيه مع الاسف
بالتنسيق مع قيادات كرديه هدفها الاساسي
حمايه هذا الكيان وتوسيع رقعه انتشاره
السيد ناصر الحج منصور لحظه عفوا ربما
ساعود اليك لاحقا سيد ناصر الحاج منصور ما
الغرض من مثل هذه التحركات رفع العلم
الكردي طرد السكان العرب ا يعني نشر
الخرائط على النحو الذي قال به السيد بسام
جعاره عدد مقاتلي وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكردي بتقدير مجموعه الازمات الدوليه
يبلغ 30,000 يتلقون رواتب شهريه مقداره 4
ونص مليون دولار من اين تاتي هذه الاموال
ولماذا كل هذا التجهيز لم تكن هناك اذا لم
تكن هناك لاقامه
دوله اخي الكريم
ا نحن نقاتل داعش نحن لا نلعب لعبه اطفال
نحن لا نتحدث من لندن نحن نجابه الموت
يوما وراء اخر كل منا له اخوته واخواته
واهله واهله في هذه المعركه يقاتلون
والاخر يتحدث من هنا ومن هناك ويتحدث عن
اي تهجير عرقي وما شابه ويتحدث باشياء لا
اساس لها من الصحه الجيش الحر لازال في ت
الابيض ولا زالت اعلامه مرفوعه في ت
الابيض وهو يقول انهم قد طردوا هذا الجيش
الحر وما شابه ثوار الرقه منذ اشهر وهم
يقاتلون جنب الى جن وحدات حمايه انا نقلت
لك تقارير او نقلت لك عن بيان للثوار
شركائكم الذين تقول انهم موجودون نقلت
عنهم اتهامات لكم بارتكاب مجازر وارتكاب
عمليات تطهير عرقي ويهددون بالرد ليس ليس
لها ليس لها مكان من الصحه استاذي الكريم
ليس لها مكان من الصحه اذا
كان
هذا شيف ناصج بس لحظه لحظه استاذ الكريم
ليس هناك و اسمع بس نص دقيقه فقط
منغ استغربه استاذ الكريم شي اللي استغربه
كل ما داعش يعني امر طبيعي ان يحاول هؤلاء
نفي كل الجرائم التي يرتكبوها سال ضيفك بس
سؤال من يقاتل في راس العين اليسوا مرتزقه
بلاك وتر هناك الاف المرتزقه الذين
يقاتلون يتهمون تركيا ولكن من جاء بهؤلاء
الى راس العين ليقاتلوا مع هذه الوحدات
بدي اقول كلمه اهم معظم المقاتلين مع صابه
صالح مسلم هم من المرتزقه الاجانب ومن
الاكراد الذين اتوا من تركيا ومن العراق
معظم شباب الاكراد في سوريا هاجروا الى
اوروبا شكرا جزي ل شكرا جزيلا لك السيد
بسام جعاره الكاتب والاعلامي السوري
المعارض وكان معنا من مدينه عموده في
محافظه الحسكه السيد ناصر الحاج منصور
مسؤول العلاقات في هيئه الدفاع بالاداره
الذاتيه لمقاطعه الجزيره ومن اسطنبول كان
معنا سمير صالحه رئيس قسم العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه كوجا ايلي اشكركم
مشاهدينا الاعزاء بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
تعالى في قراءه جديده في م وراء خبر جديد
السلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم
ه